okay so first let me just introduce you
the introduce the chat and peter uh
to you the game surya has solved uh
quite a few of them so he knows what
this is about it's
you've got
you've got five turns
to guess the opening that chessel wants
you to guess
and you have to put in the moves
uh for example let's start with
something suggest a move the first five
moves
and it will tell you how many of them
are right and in which
number
what move number is it right as well so
you have to try to guess but it's going
to be an opening it is a valid opening
that chessel wants you to guess so first
let's just start with the five moves
that you suggest
okay so e4 i'm suggesting
e4 okay keep going
yeah okay e5
all right hopeful hopefully that's what
chester wants me to play okay
okay then then king's gonna beat people
are always asking for king's gambit i'm
gonna go f4 then all right peter playing
with the spectators all right so f4 and
then
e takes
f4 knight f3
so hang on but i should not not show my
best preparation here right i mean okay
okay g5 let's go g5 then let's go peter
thinking about preparation here
i mean
you can think like this
yeah d4 d4
d6
and uh bishop c4
bishop g7 am i'm disqualified or i'm
still in the game
now we submit
now we submit right
oh wow peter you did horrible because
this is the situation now out of all
these moves the only correct move that
is in the sequence of five moves is the
move knight f3 but it's not on the right
spot it's not on move number three
so the good news is you haven't given
out any great preparation the bad news
is that you're doing pretty bad at
castle right now
yeah okay so i will i will start playing
tariq then with first move knight fc
just trying to be more solid yeah this
time yeah but it also says that you uh
in this five moves why did not play e4
d4 black did not play you know moves
like d6 bishop g7
so exactly like
must have played c4 or g3 at some point
yeah yeah so after knight fc okay and
avid black i have to play something like
okay c5 i i haven't done it before
yes that's a good choice because it
wasn't played in our first submit yes so
now i'm gonna play g3 i will be very
very positional knight c6
c4
get the center get the center
yeah then
okay knight f6 development
we need to develop the knights knight c3
i can still play yeah okay i'm gonna go
knight c3
nice
and uh and okay i go g6 symmetrical
stuff
and you go g6 yeah yes
yeah but but i know that i can't play
bishop g7 so i can play bishop g2 so i
go bishop g2 and navi's black i go d5
okay so chad these are the five
submissions uh let's see how many of
them
wow surya this one went well
yeah yeah yeah yeah you see i'm
improving
so basically we can deduce the first
movie c4
right more or less
c4 is the first move
i mean if it is not knight f3 move one
it's unlikely it will be g3 on knight c3
and i see it's not legally possible so
it has to be g3 or c4
yes what i mean
finally one movie is at the right spot
yeah
yeah yeah but this is actually a lot of
fun it's it's a lot of fun i love this
and i'm doing this every day and peter
it only you only get one a day and then
it resets so what's the first move here
all right let's go c4c5 peter yeah let's
go c4 c4 c5 on the board let's let's do
knight f3 knight f6
knight f3 knight f6
now knight c3 knight c6 i think i'm
still doing fine
okay and peter what about you what would
be the fourth move that you want to
suggest here well okay g3 definitely um
g3 should be it okay
and then we go d5 here yeah with black
yes
but the only problem is
here we are struggling when to put
bishop g2
no but bishop g2 is not the right move
no
yeah so we cannot put bishop g2 so which
means yeah but why can't we take just
cd5
yeah cd5 cd59d5 yeah and then we have it
now i think we are we are you think this
is it you think this is it you think you
guys got this one
yes yes
oh my god all right chad this is the
moment of truth
um i i'll have to scroll down a bit i
hope it's
fine with the screen yeah we're okay
so
you did it peter you did it
but you see thanks to sudia swedia is
the expert okay thank you very much
that was amazing it was your first try
and we had put the bar for peter at
three surya and he managed to do it this
was the english opening the four nights
variation so we got some information and
of course we've got a new opening quiz
every day on castle and if you like the
opening you see and want to learn more
about it go on to chessable and there
would be a course that you can check out
on it